[Musik]
ja was geht bei dir stets zwei spitzen
hallo
die bereit dafür für was die vernichtung
der gehirnzellen zu ja klar das sieht
zwar aus wie ein schwein ist aber
gefährlicher als ein grizzlybär das
killer schweiz
[Musik]
das macht 150 waren sie mit viel wasser
wer machen sie es nicht mehr
falsch diesen jungen sie fragt sie die
leute auf tik tok haye hat irgend eine
eigenschaft die wenn ihr es von eurem
freund macht dazu führen könnte dass er
sich von euch trend also ich bin
gespannt auf ihre eigenschaft und jetzt
dreht sich den kopf automatisch
nachricht check diesen trend machen
[Musik]
warum mache ich nur was so eine scheiße
marius kommen hier ist bestimmt nein
marius also die mutter von marius hat
mario sein neues t shirt gekauft dass
marius enck findet die mutter allerdings
nicht also ich bin gespannt wie das t
shirt aussieht
[Gelächter]
das würde ich eventuell eine oder sieben
nummern größer kaufen schnell antworten
und über nachzudenken okay was trinkt
ein vampir blut was fließt durch seine
adern blut was nimmt der arzt mit der
spritze blut und wann gehst für die
ampel bei rot grün
ja ich finde ich gut
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der trend bei uns nicht mal post richtig
für die kabine gelassen ich hoffe
einfach unglaublich was ich bin ganz
ehrlich ich bin ganz ehrlich das ist
eine richtig richtig gute folge tuesday
heute am donnerstag gibt es bio ist das
team von titanic
[Musik]
acom ich muss mich jetzt mal
zusammenreißen der gab
kriegt nicht so you can use
moment ich glaube das hatten wir schon
mal und zwar ist dass dieser kartei
filter und du kannst ein
[Musik]
das voraus also ich könnte jetzt
und dann
typisch menschen nicht gesehen ziemlich
abstoßend
[Musik]
ich werde sie war die einzige die mich
in der schule immer abschreiben lassen
[Musik]
ich schwöre warum
dg
aber das gehört aber ich habe es so laut
geschrieben das einfach meine ukulele da
oben
ich sagte ja und auch noch erst so guckt
dann guckt er weg oder guckt einfach
wieder sie ab
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wahrheit begann
einfach die wahrheit es macht gar keinen
sinn aber mal macht ist immer und immer
und immer und wenn ich dich nach einer
frage ist wieso was ich gar nichts zu
tun haben
seine stimme ist so wie die alpen das
ging schon die ganze zeit hoch und
runter sagt aber ist die wahrheit ist
die wahrheit als irgendjemand von meinen
abonnenten geradezu schauen sollte und
in den letzten zehn jahren irgendwie in
den kollegen von euch deren blatt haben
wollte einst in dieser krise gegeben hat
[Musik]
bedarf uns männer wie objekte zu
behandeln ich habe nie solche hosen habe
ich nie an allerdings
laut meine lieben freunde ich habe mein
eigenes gesicht vor einigen tagen auf
der homepage entdeckt und es war kein
tik tok dass ich hochgeladen habe
sondern folgendes video
[Musik]
es ist ein screen recording der
instagram story von meiner schwester
während wir an weihnachten als familie
ein spiel gespielt haben und die tik tok
userin schreibt dazu oh mein gott dieser
blick und es hat 120000 likes egal
ich habe keine ahnung was an meinem
blick so attraktiv sein sollen
[Musik]
er ist für dich ist nicht mehr ganz
dicht würste reporter wissen bescheid
ich kann ja nicht rücken und immer wenn
ich versuche kommen
apropos podcast meine lieben freunde
sein und ich der winterpause also hatte
ich die neue folge an die heute nacht
online gegangen ist party feiern die uns
lustig und du
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich den kreativitäts preis
schon vergeben aber du kriegst definitiv
platz zwei
ich habe mir du hast doch mit einem
freund schluss macht was los es hat nur
ein kunde kann man wirklich nicht mehr
mit jenem tag nacheinander ist - anders
aus ich warte mal du behindert ich
musste mich für dich entscheiden oder
für sie aber ich habe es für dich hinzu
die amerikaner so kreative ideen und
dann kommen die deutschen besonders am
neckar ist normal dass ich dabei gerade
mehr mitgefiebert habe als bei allen
fußball weltmeisterschaften zusammen
ich glaube das ist das kreativste
speed
wenn man links war es muss ich mir
denken ich bin gespannt kannte ja die
alte tante im supermarkt das ist das
korrekt also da muss ich sie aber
wirklich also das ist auch korrekt so
viel alkohol trinkt wir jetzt nicht als
ich glaube schon dass das dann auch war
es wird anzeige in der ferne also so
häufig suchen sagen wer hält wenn also
das war alles richtig
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
dann alle hundeliebhaber
dann geht man bedenke da wir nun die
ganzen katzenliebhaber und auch
hundeliebhaber zufriedengestellt haben
stellen wir nun mich zufrieden
film ab
[Musik]
die antwort bestimmt
mit
[Musik]